und in Istanbul grüße ich nun unseren
Korrespondenten Oliver meyer-rüht wie
ist denn die Lage bei Ihnen wie sieht es
denn am Flughafen aus was können Sie uns
denn berichten
ja laut Flugplan sind heute an den
beiden Flughäfen in Istanbul und an dem
Flughafen in Antalya in den letzten 24
Stunden 100 Flieger aus Russland
gelandet die Flieger für die nächsten
Tage sollen alle ausgebucht sein die
Preise haben sich vervielfacht da ist
teilweise von Flugpreisen von 2000 Euro
die Rede und es kommen einfach sehr sehr
viele Russen jetzt hier an gerade in
Antalya gibt es schon eine große
russische Gemeinde Gemeinschaft und die
wird sich wahrscheinlich in den nächsten
Tagen noch vergrößern aber es ist eben
auch so dass viele hierher nach Istanbul
fliegen um eben in ein anderen Flieger
zu steigen und in einer in anderes waren
Land weiter zu fliegen ja ich wollte sie
gerade fragen was hören sie denn so gab
es vielleicht die Möglichkeit mal mit
jungen Russen zu sprechen wir haben zum
Beispiel auch gelesen dass die meisten
sich aus naheliegenden Gründen nur ein
One World Ticket geholt haben
ja das ist richtig es kommen eben viele
junge russische Männer aus den
Flugzeugen am Flughafen an und wir
konnten mit welchen reden der eine hat
dann eben gleich gesagt ja er sei jetzt
hier er hätte sein Land verlassen wegen
dieser
teilmobilenmachung Wolle auf gar keinen
Fall an diesem Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine teilnehmen es gebe jetzt eben
auch ein Gesetz in Russland dass wenn
man sich gegen diese teilmobil machen
gegen diese Mobilmachung weigere dass
einem dann zehn Jahre Haft drohen und da
hätte er mit seiner Familie gesprochen
und man hätte gemeinsam entschieden dass
er jetzt einfach erstmal auf unbestimmte
Zeit seine Heimat verlässt ein anderer
Mann mit dem wir auch sprechen konnten
der allerdings auch anonym bleiben
wollte übrigens haben sehr viele die da
aus den Flugzeugen kamen und die wir
angesprochen haben gesagt sie wollen
nicht gefilmt werden also dieser Mann
hat gesagt er wolle eben auf gar keinen
Fall an diesem sinnlosen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine teilnehmen und auch nicht in
diesem sinnlosen Krieg sein Leben
verlieren ja das sieht also wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe im Moment so aus dass
die Maschinen aus Moskau noch planmäßig
ankommen also der russische Staat die
russische Regierung gestrichen wird der
im Moment wohl noch nichts
den Eindruck habe ich nicht dass da
irgendwas gestrichen wird allerdings
hört man auch dass eben unter Umständen
in Russland schon ja im Zuge dieser
Mobilmachung nach möglichen jungen
Männern gesucht wird die dann eben
teilnehmen müssen und die Frage ist
natürlich dann ob da jeder ohne weiteres
in nächster Zeit eben Russland auch
verlassen kann in der Ukraine war es ja
eben auch nach Kriegsbedingungen auch so
dass die Männer in bärfigen alter das
Land nicht mehr verlassen konnten und
ich kann mir vorstellen dass es sowas in
Russland unter Umständen dann auch in
den nächsten Tagen auch geben wird
können Sie uns denn eventuell was
darüber sagen also wie die türkische
Gesellschaft den jungen Russen gegenüber
steht die da kommen wie sie aufgenommen
werden
also ist ja sowieso schon so dass seit
Beginn dieses russischen Angriffs Krieg
Kriegs gegen die Ukraine sehr viele
Russen aber auch Ukraine hierher nach
Istanbul kamen das waren vor allem
Oppositionelle es waren sehr viel gut
ausgebildete junge Menschen die dann oft
so in der Softwarebranche arbeiten und
die dann eben auch hier ihrem Job
nachgehen können normalerweise kommen
die hierher und haben erstmal einen
Visum ein Touristenvisum für 90 Tage und
dann kann es natürlich unter Umständen
sein wenn sie das Land nicht verlassen
dass sie dann Probleme bekommen mit den
Behörden hier in der Türkei aber da
haben wir auch gehört dass es wohl bei
den Behörden dann irgendwann geheißen
hat wir drücken da bei denen beide Augen
zu es ist ja auch so hier in der Türkei
wenn man diese 90 Tage überschreitet und
dann irgendwann das Land verlässt dann
muss man eigentlich am Flughafen nur
eine geringe Geldstrafe zahlen um dann
wieder ausreisen zu können und ich kann
mir vorstellen wenn jetzt eben diese
jungen Männer hier bekommen dann wird
man den erstmal keine Probleme machen da
gibt es sicherlich viel Verständnis hier
und dann ist es eben auch immer die
Frage haben sie Geld wenn sie Geld haben
dann empfängt Sie der türkische Staat
mit offenen Armen ja ich bedanke mich
herzlich für diese Schilderung nach
Istanbul bei Oliver meier-rüdt danke
sehr